région est bien la savoie au mois de
septembre
c'est bien entendu ce département
souriant qui commence à faire ses
comptes après une saison touristique qui
paraissait au début bien compromise et
qui sont toutes s'avérera finalement
plus satisfaisante qu'on ne l'espérait
l'année dernière alors qu'il était
encore secrétaire d'état au tourisme
monsieur dumas montrait une nouvelle
fois l'exemple en matière d'accueil des
touristes étrangers en lançant
l'opération tasse de thé qui permettait
au jeune savoyard d'amorcer un fructueux
dialogue avec leurs amis d'outre-rhin
et bien c'est une opération tasse de thé
ou de café selon les goûts des gens elle
consiste comme je l'expliquais à les
charmantes voisine à permettre à des
familles françaises de rencontrer des
familles ou des personnes que les
vacances sont amenés dans notre pays
en effet le tourisme doit être une
occasion non pas seulement voir des
paysages mais pour les hommes de se
connaître et peut-être de se comprendre
mieux ensuite je pense aussi que les
français veulent montrer leur joie
d'accueillir de très nombreux touristes
étrangers je crois 12 millions cette
année et c'est pourquoi je me suis
permis de demander à des familles
françaises de recevoir non pas pour
déjeuner ce que nous faisons avec tetro
de solennité et trop difficilement les
pour le café très simplement des
familles étrangères de passage ça a été
fait l'année dernière dans le val de
loire nous l'étendons à d'autres régions
en france cette année
et puisque la savoie aujourd'hui à son
tour entrer dans le jeu eh bien je suis
très heureux d'y participer de
participer à l'opération en tant que
savoyard moi-même pour cette brève
vacances et c'est ce qui nous vaut le
plaisir d'avoir à côté de moi une jeune
américaine venu du massachusetts
une dame une dame anglaise venue d'
exécuteur avec toute sa famille et qui
est déjà d'ailleurs une habituée de la
france mais qui pour la première fois se
trouvent dans cette région des alpes
j'espère que les relations ainsi noué à
travers toute la france entre français
et étrangers permettront de
consolider la compréhension entre les
différentes